in former times Europe used to have
large mammals like the European wild
horse neo rock and also the European
bison we lost the European wild horse we
lost the Europe both got extinct and we
nearly lost European bison
meanwhile in Europe is a new
conservation initiative in Europe trying
to make Europe a while the place the
bison plays a very important role we say
it is a keystone species and European
landscapes because of its grazing and
browsing behavior it has an impact on
the vegetation and the landscape and
that brings new species in the system in
fact we are here in Armenian Romania
these bison that have been brought here
today have travelled a few thousand
kilometers by Road people from the local
community from the municipality may hope
is here there is a whole community
around camenisch which of course is very
interested and also excited about this
initiative the animals get out of the
truck they don't run away they just hang
around they put their horns on the
ground and they start fighting with each
other it's their way of trying to get
used to place we release them in small
groups into a small area then we release
them into the wild
everybody knows Europe having a
fantastic cultural heritage but we also
have a beautiful natural heritage
it's amazing to see how nature responds
and how species come back it would be a
tragedy if we would lose another big
mammal what we hope of course has
rewilding Europe is that large herds of
bison can roam our landscapes again and
people can enjoy it
you